اعتقلت قوه الاحتلال خمسه فلسطينيين من
مخيم عقبه جبر بمدينه اريحا خلال حمله
اعتقالات شنتها في بلدات وقرى ومدن
فلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه بما في ذلك
القدس المحتله منعت قوه الاحتلال طواقم
الاسعاف من الوصول الى احد المصابين بعد
وقوع اشتباكات مسلحه مع مقاومين ومواجهات
مع شباب مخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا وفي بلده
قباطيه جنوبيه جنين اي انسحبت قوات
الاحتلال بعد فشالها في اعتقال احد الشبان
كما اقتحمت قوته الاحتلال ايضا بلده ترم
السعيه شماليه رام الله وقريه كفر قدوم في
قلقيليه اعتقلت في مدينه الخليل وفي بلده
العيساويه بالقدس المحتله عددا من
الفلسطينيين بعد عمليات دهم لمنازلهم
من رام الله مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو شماله
ينضم الينا سمير اهلا بك كيف تتابع كل هذه
التطورات
نعم سفيان في سياق ما تشنه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه في كل يوم على مدن وبلدات
وقرى في الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله
تستمر هذه العمليات خلال الليله الماضيه
كان هناك عمليه اقتحام لعشرات الاليات
العسكريه
الاسرائيليه لبلده جنوبي مدينه جنين وقد
حصلت احد المنازل وطلبت الشاب محمد كميل
وهو المطلوب لدى القوات الاحتلال
الايطاليه بتسليم نفسه وقد دهمت المنزل
ولكنها لم تعثر عليه وفشلت في اعتقاده
ولكنها لم تخرج من البلده خاليه الوفاضه
لكنها ابقت على اعتقال والد المطلوب وهو
احمد كميل واحتجزته ونقلته معه وذلك في
محاوله للضغط على ابنه لتسليم نفه لنفسه
للقوات الاسرائيليه وقد تخلل ذلك اشتباكات
مسلحه مع مجموعات قباطيه التابعه للصرايا
القدس الذراع المسلح لحركه الجهاد الاسلام
وايضا مع كتائبي شهداء الاقصى
التابعه لحركه فتح في بيانين منفصلين تبنت
اشتباكات مسلح مع قوات الاحتلال خلال هذه
العمليه بالتزامن مع ذلك كان هناك ايضا
عمليات اقتحام لقوه خاصه اسرائيليه اقتحمت
مخيم عقبه جبر في مدينه اريحا وحاصرت احد
المنازل واعتقلت سبعه شبان على الاقل داخل
المخيم وكذا هناك اشتباكات وايضا مواجهات
مع شبان المخيم خرجوا للتصدي لهذه القوات
الاسرائيليه مما ادى الى اصابه احد الشبان
الفلسطينيين بالرصاص في منطقه الساق وحسب
المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه وجراحه بين
طفيفه ومتوسطه اضافه الى ذلك كان هناك
ايضا اقتحام ودهم لعدد اخر البلدات والقرى
في الضفه الغربيه في مدينه الخليل وايضا
في كفر قدوم في قلقيليه
وفي مخيم الدهيش وقريه الطاس في مدينه بيت
لحم هناك كان ايضا هناك حمله اعتقالات
طالت اربعه فلسطينيين في بيت لحم واخرين
حتى في رام الله هنا كان في ترمس عيا في
شمال مدينه رام الله وفي مخيم قدوره في
داخل وسط مدينه رام الله كان اعتقال
لشابين بن مخيم قدوره وايضا لشاب بن ترمس
علي وبالتالي هذه العمليات استمرت حتى
طالت ايضا بلده العيساويه وضواحي في مدينه
القدس المحتله واعتقلت عددا من
الفلسطينيين هناك وتبلغ حصيله المعتقلين
منذ بدايه هذا العام
حسبنا به نادي الاسير الفلسطيني حتى هذه
اللحظه الى نحو 1900 اسير فلسطين تم
اعتقاله منذ بدايه هذا العام شكرا لك سمير
ابو شمالك كنت معنا من رام الله